you have an opportunity to play some
golf while helping families with
medically fragile children in southern
nevada the nonprofit the little miss
hannah foundation helps provide families
whose children have rare diseases with
special equipment and medical supplies
that typically are not covered by
insurance this non-profit was started by
carey and robert austria the parents of
three-year-old hannah who passed away
due to her rare disease the family with
the support of our generous community
has been helping other families for 10
years and it's hosting its first golf
fundraiser the morning of september 11th
at painted desert golf course fifty
percent of all proceeds go directly to
the foundation and help raise awareness
about these special children
we call the our kid little messianic
kids are vips they're you know they
really are very important people so
that's how we refer to them so on each
tea box there's a poster with their name
um their picture some fun facts about
them and their rare disease diagnosis
and as social golfers can learn about
these kids and put a face to the name
and realize oh it's not just this this
text that i'm seeing like this is a real
child of the personality and a beautiful
smile
again that's the morning of september
11th half the proceeds go to the
foundation and for more information go
to littlemisshanna.org